[Music]
we know megan has immersed herself in
royal life but what everyone's debating
today well does that include a new
British accent thank you a fan posted
this video on Twitter from the Duchess's
solo trip with the Queen last month
Markel was talking about her May 19th
wedding day so does Megan appear to have
a British accent
could it be she's got a case of the
Madonna's it's brilliant or is Megan
just being proper this morning her
accent was the topic of much debate
there's also the cadence of some of the
words yes you know the way that they
speaking of Megan and Harry's wedding
day Kensington Palace released their
official thank-you car the black and
white candid taken by photographer
Alexei Lugo mears key shows both smiling
as Megan looks off to the side on the
back of the card a touching message of
best wishes meanwhile hearing Megan
continued their Royal rounds yesterday
the pair stepped out in London for an
event to honor young leaders but it was
Megan's bright yellow brandon maxwell
dress that captured the attention the
sleeveless sheaths dress knocked down to
nearly half the $1500 asking price sold
out instantly online this marks the
start of a whirlwind of royal
engagements Monday Harry and Megan will
attend the christening of Prince William
and Kate Middleton's two and a half
month old son Prince Louie then they had
to Ireland for an official visit
[Music]